GIA MORA: Hi, everyone.
KEVIN GRAZIER: Hi.
[APPLAUSE]
GIA MORA: Well, good afternoon
to you here in the studio
and, of course, to all the
Livestreamers out there.
Welcome to another
wonderful Talk at Google.
My name is Gia Mora.
And I am one third of The
Scirens-- The Screen Scirens
for Science.
And with me today is
Dr. Kevin Grazier.
KEVIN GRAZIER: Hi.
GIA MORA: Kevin is not only
a PhD In planetary science
known for his work on the
Cassini-Huygens project
at NASA, but he's also
a writer, an educator,
a sought after public
speaker, and-- what we're here
to talk about today-- he is
a science adviser for hit TV
shows and blockbuster
movies in Hollywood.
Now, that is quite a
list of accomplishments
for a boy from Sterling
Heights, Michigan, I believe?
KEVIN GRAZIER: Yeah, yeah.
GIA MORA: Is that
what you intended?
Did you think, oh I'm going to
get a PhD in planetary science
from UCLA.
I'm going to go
work in Hollywood.
KEVIN GRAZIER: The
PhD was planned.
The Hollywood thing
came in later.
I literally transferred,
in midstream, PhD programs.
I was actually in a
PhD program in Purdue,
where I had done my
undergrad and Master's.
But I decided to
go to UCLA instead.
Partly because I
wanted to work at JPL.
And it was right across town.
And that worked out pretty well.
But when I discovered
that Hollywood Science
Advisor is a thing, oh yeah.
I totally wanted to do that.
So I decided that yeah, that
would be something that I
think I would enjoy doing.
But I also wanted to write.
So I was hoping that one
would lead to the other.
So that was the plan.
At least initially.
So yeah.
GIA MORA: Great.
So for those of
you who don't know,
tell us what is a
Hollywood Science Adviser?
KEVIN GRAZIER: Well,
Science Advisor
works on science fiction
or science-themed shows.
And we work on getting the
science as right as possible.
It doesn't have to be perfect.
We're not doing documentaries.
Sometimes perfect science
is not only not a goal,
it's opposite to some of
the goals you may have.
Sometimes you don't want
to get science perfect.
But you want to get it
as right as possible.
Because what you want
to do is sell the world.
You want to sell that this
is a well-thought-out world.
And if you throw
some science out
that's at variance with
the way the world works,
or with people, how to
understand the world works,
they get what's called an Oh
Please moment, where suddenly,
rather than being immersed in
your creative vision, they go,
no.
No, please.
And suddenly, they go
from being immersed
in the world of
defiance to sitting
in a room in the 20th century
with four walls, a ceiling
and a floor, going no.
Just-- you lost me.
And so that's what
we do, is we try
to get the science
as right as possible
to minimize the
Oh Please moments.
GIA MORA: OK so in sustaining
the suspension of disbelief,
you use real science.
Is there any other
ulterior motives,
as a PhD planetary scientist?
KEVIN GRAZIER: As far
as ulterior motives,
even if your science
isn't perfect-- wow,
that's like a
really good lead in.
Even if your science
isn't perfect,
if you're working on
a big-budget Hollywood
show or a feature, you will
get opportunities-- like here
and now-- to set
the record straight.
If people have
questions-- was this true?
Or if people will say,
maybe, jump over your science
in a big-budget 2013 film--
GIA MORA:
[CLEARING THROAT DELIBERATELY]
"Gravity".
KEVIN GRAZIER: Yeah.
GIA MORA: Yeah.
KEVIN GRAZIER: --then
you get the opportunity
to do talks, DVD extras,
or write books like oh,
say, "Hollyweird Science", to
talk about the actual science
that came into play.
And what you find is oftentimes
some of the complaints
are non-issues.
Some of the complaints
are, themselves, riddled
with mistakes.
So again, we're trying
to sell the world,
trying to minimize the
"oh please" moments.
And that does come
with the benefits
of being able to help educate
on the real world science.
Absolutely.
GIA MORA: Great.
That was going to
my next question.
So why should Hollywood care?
Not the audience, but
why should Hollywood--
producers, directors,
writers-- why should they
care about good science
in science fiction
or in popular culture at
large, in entertainment?
KEVIN GRAZIER: We're getting
a lot better at storytelling
across the board.
And let me use the
example of shows
I've worked on, like Battlestar
and "Eureka" and "Defiance",
there was a dedication to
excellence across the board,
getting created languages
done well was a thing.
Selling the world was a thing.
And getting the science
as right as possible
was a desire to do
the best job we can.
But apart from that,
Hollywood cares
because we have a culture
of the nitpicker now.
If you get something
wrong, guaranteed
there's going to somebody online
complaining about it-- well,
it's a film-- the
second the film's over.
Unless, of course,
they're actually
tweeting from their seat.
And there is that.
So if you get too many
people nitpicking,
it can ruin your bottom line.
So when "Gravity" started
getting nitpicked,
before the film even came
out, I got calls from Warner,
saying, hey, could you
talk to this person
or talk to what this
person is saying?
Or could you go on
the "CBS Morning Show"
and discuss some of the
science of "Gravity"?
So they were worried about
what the nitpicking could
do to impact their film.
Like that was going to matter.
It was a great film.
But still, they did send me out.
They said, go talk
to these people.
Would you please
talk to these people?
Because they cared.
So there's a
dedication to getting
accurate and good storytelling.
But there's also a bottom
line to be considered as well.
GIA MORA: What about
the usefulness as a tool
to bring science literacy
to a general public
through entertainment?
KEVIN GRAZIER: Oh,
well, then you're
talking "Hollyweird Science".
The books--
GIA MORA: Wait,
you mean the book?
KEVIN GRAZIER: The book.
GIA MORA: Your book, that you're
about to have a second version
of coming out in 2016?
KEVIN GRAZIER: Yes, that.
GIA MORA: Do you mean this book?
KEVIN GRAZIER: Yes.
So Stephen Cass,
my Co-Author, he
pitched a panel at
Comic-Con in 2007.
And it was called Science
of Science Fiction.
And it was three people.
It was myself, and
it was Jaime Paglia,
my Showrunner from "Eureka", and
Phil Plait, the Bad Astronomer.
And it was a smash.
We filled a huge room.
And so it's been a thing
every year since then.
It's changed names.
But we saw the power
of science fiction
to teach the real science.
And that's one of the
things that I latched
onto when I got a job
as a Science Advisor,
is I'm going to be
able to actually use
this to teach the real science.
So Stephen and I started the
"Hollyweird Science" books.
And we decided that in
addition to taking examples
from TV and film and
saying, this is good
and this is bad, we
would also approach this
from the screenwriter's
standpoint,
so that people understand
why it's not always good.
And why sometimes it's bad,
and maybe even bad on purpose.
I've used that example twice.
Let me give you an example
about bad on purpose.
"Breaking Bad" and "CSI" are
shows that actively, at times,
degrade the accuracy
of their science.
Because on your
hour-long drama, you
don't want to be
teaching people how
to build bombs or make meth.
So they would actively try
to make it seem real but not.
So we decided we would
use these books to teach
the real science.
But rather than
getting in the muck
of the cult of the nitpicker,
we decided early on
that no one wants
to read 250, 300
pages of negativity or snark.
Except maybe the nitpickers.
GIA MORA: I was going
to say, isn't that
what the internet is?
It's just page
after page of snark.
KEVIN GRAZIER: It
can be if you let it.
If you want to go to one
of the quotes we have,
"The lowest vibrations
of human existence."
Yes, it can be that.
But we decided to stay positive.
We're not beneath
calling someone
on the carpet for
really bad science.
And in Chapter 3,
I go off on a film
that I thought had the worst
depiction of scientists ever.
(WHISPERING) "Red Planet".
"Red Planet"-- horrible science.
Oh, scientists.
The scientists were
really-- ah, no.
I just-- Anyway, so we
will complain judiciously.
But generally, we stay positive.
We try to make it a positive
educational experience,
while at the same time,
helping people understand
the screenwriter care abouts,
the director care abouts
and what it's like
to actually craft
an hour-long drama or a
film with science concerns.
GIA MORA: Sure.
I understand the
perspective of the writer
to need to tell their narrative.
What do you attribute
the audience's change
in needing science
to be accurate?
Is it just because of the
comments of the internet?
Is it because science has become
more of a cultural phenomenon
at large, that more and more
people are interested in
and care about?
Or is it driven by the
screenwriter's need
to tell these narratives?
KEVIN GRAZIER: There's a lot
of things that you asked there.
And one of the things
we continually hear
is how bad American
science literacy is.
But when you hear
that quoted, it
turns out they're
quoting K12 numbers.
But when you get to
adults, turns out
that Americans are second in
the world in science literacy
behind only Sweden.
Which explains why they
make great cell phones.
Right?
And by the way, before
people say, yeah!
Our science literacy is bad.
It's not as bad as a
lot of other countries
at the adult level.
And that's been
attributed to the fact
that we all have to take
science electives in college,
at least one.
And that's different at
variance with other countries.
So we're generally
reasonably science literate.
And there's the
internet, where a lot
of science literacy and science
illiteracy can get propagated.
And also, when you've got people
complaining about something--
and sometimes these are
trolls, people who are just
mean-spirited people who just
want to pick on something--
we did a panel recently, at
the WonderCon convention,
about Hollywood science
and science in TV and film.
And Ashley Miller,
who's a screenwriter,
he said something that I think
was really, really important.
He says, it's easy to see on the
internet five people tweeting
and think it's a movement.
Because they're
talking so loudly
and complaining so vociferously
that you realize that there's
a whole bunch of people who
are just taking this in,
and may even be saying,
you're kind of a boob.
Or maybe saying, dude, that's
totally right, or whatever.
So you just can't tell.
But sometimes it's the
squeaky wheel kind of thing.
GIA MORA: Right.
So are there squeaky wheels
that say positive things?
Like, wow, I saw gravity.
And now I, seven-year-old
girl, think
I'm going to be an
astronaut when I grow up.
KEVIN GRAZIER: There are some.
There are some who have
said, this is fantastic.
I mean, I think the seven Oscars
said somebody kind of liked it,
whether or not the
science sold it.
I mean, yeah, the science
was both the protagonist
and the antagonist in
that film, wasn't it?
GIA MORA: Sure.
KEVIN GRAZIER:
The antagonist was
the Kessler syndrome and the
propagation of orbital debris.
And the solution, there were
several scientific solutions
that just sequentially
solved one problem at a time,
till you get to the end.
GIA MORA: Right.
I mean, we have
three basic stories.
Right?
Man vs. Man, Man vs.
Nature, and Man vs. Himself.
KEVIN GRAZIER: Right.
And you had all
three, in this case.
GIA MORA: It's true.
She's got to overcome her
psychological hallucinations.
Spoiler alert.
Sorry.
But she's also got to
fight her way against being
in outer space, which
is certainly difficult.
And "The Martian",
of course, deals
with many of the same
sort of thematic elements.
KEVIN GRAZIER:
And "The Martian",
we interviewed Andy Weir
for the second book, which
we are wrapping up right now.
"Beyond Hollywood Science"
is dominating my life right now.
Literally, I spend every
waking hour writing,
when I'm not teaching
my astronomy class.
The second book, the subtitle
is "From Rocket Ships
to Microchips".
And we talk a lot
about space things.
We actually interviewed Andy
Weir about "The Martian".
And essentially, "The Martian"
is a classical cascade failure
told on a Martian setting,
with a very human element.
GIA MORA: So stories like "The
Martian" and "Gravity" are not,
in my mind, what I would
think of as classic examples
of science fiction.
Although they, by
definition, are.
But the idea of
science fiction being
sort of these
dystopic worlds that
allow us to examine cultural
phenomenon that are happening
now, but through
a different lens
with a different perspective.
Of course, you had "Defiance".
You had "Battlestar Galactica".
Those are what I would think
of as more classical sci-fi.
So tell me more about that.
Tell me the difference
between working
on a project like
"Gravity", which
is driven by the limitations or
the structures of what we know
we can control,
versus a world where
it's "Battlestar Galactica".
Like, there's a whole
other universe of reality
there, that we've already
solved the whole long-term space
travel problem.
KEVIN GRAZIER: Wow,
there's a lot there.
But this might go a long
way towards addressing
that succinctly.
Is that there is a term used--
and I'm dating myself here--
for the series, "Space:
1999", in the mid '70s.
And they called it
Science Faction,
where that wasn't that
far in the distant future.
The technology
wasn't a big leap.
At least, the technology of
the humans wasn't a big leap.
They would eventually
encounter aliens.
So it's where you're
telling the story
in the not-too-distant
future, where
the technology is plausible.
And I can see that.
Even if there's leaps,
they're not really big leaps.
And they're things that you can
reasonably project for things
that are here in the now.
So "Gravity" and "The
Martian", I'd say,
would fall into that
realm, where you're just
making sure you get the
science as right as possible,
with a few story conceits
that we understood going in.
Well, firstly, another thing
I'm just writing about now
is a lot of the real-world
issues about space travel
are completely obviated
by something that's
a production consideration.
It's artificial gravity.
A lot of the horrible things
that happen to the human body
just go away with
artificial gravity.
But if you don't have
artificial gravity,
you're showing people floating.
And how many
productions do that?
"The Expanse" did it.
"Apollo 13" did it.
And they did it in the Vomit
Comet, with the KC-135.
Or not KC, the 135 that dives.
And you get 20 seconds
of weightlessness.
GIA MORA: Yeah, as an actor,
I'm both titillated by that idea
and absolutely horrified.
That, like, you have
20 seconds to shoot
your scene while you're
actively wanting to throw up.
KEVIN GRAZIER: No pressure.
GIA MORA: None at all.
None at all.
KEVIN GRAZIER: It's
my understanding,
for people who've done
that, that people usually
lose it on about the
sixth parabola, out of 48.
GIA MORA: Oh!
I'm going to lose it
just hearing that.
That sounds rough.
KEVIN GRAZIER: That's actually
something that we talk about
in this next book,
is you never see--
except for in the
beginning of "Gravity"--
people suffering
from space sickness.
GIA MORA: Right.
KEVIN GRAZIER: And
there's a reason for that.
You don't want to, in the
middle of your dramatic scene,
excuse me.
And somebody goes and then--
GIA MORA: Well, sure.
I mean, that speaks
to the mundanity.
And I'm not even sure I'm
saying that word correctly.
But the mundane
existence, in some ways.
Like, if you're
on the ISS, you're
surrounded by wires
and these things.
And you have a mission.
And you have this work
that you're doing.
And it's regulated.
And you have sleep schedules.
And you have this.
That, in and of
itself, is not fodder.
It's not "Melrose Place", right?
KEVIN GRAZIER: It's not.
And in fact, on ISS, the flight
engineers spend a lot of time
doing maintenance.
And then the next
day, they wake up,
and they go back and do
maintenance all day again.
One of the problems
they found with ISS--
and that's going to be
addressed in future missions--
is that their time
is over scheduled.
They have no free time of
their or, or little free time
of their own, or not
enough free time,
that they feel that they're
overburdened with that.
And here I am in space.
And I'm fixing the toilet.
Because the fan broke.
And without that,
this could get ugly.
But there's all
those things that
get in the way of the
story, unless they
become front and center.
Which they could.
But then again, there's a
production consideration
of artificial gravity.
So that mitigates a
lot of potential drama,
because of the
production consideration.
And one thing that
I find-- and this
is a complaint I make
in the second book--
is that when people
want to complain,
you may not like something.
And you have no other
complaint so you just say,
oh, there's sound in space.
That's a common complaint.
We get that by now.
And what the people
have found, there's
studies that the audience
is actually pulled out
of the drama as much when
you don't show sound in space
as when you do.
I mean, "Gravity" didn't.
"Firefly" didn't.
But some shows, you're
satisfied with that,
with knowing that, seeing
that immediate sound or action
sound.
Jane Espenson,
whose screenwriter
was on a panel of
science in Hollywood,
she said, why don't
we just consider
that part of the soundtrack?
Solved.
So you get rid of that.
But that's a common
complaint when people just
want to complain.
But I guess a more common
complaint you could make,
is why don't people complain
about the artificial gravity?
Because that's just
as big of a trope.
It's used just as often.
And yet, there's so many
things you could do.
So my point is, when people
go to the no sound in space,
it's just lost its meaning.
GIA MORA: Right.
Well, we've been sort
of preconditioned
to expect a lot of
different kinds of sounds,
things that you and I would not
be sitting here and wondering,
like, why is her water
bottle not cracking?
But in the movies,
they're going to add it.
And it's like--
[CRACKING SOUND]
Right?
Because we want to have
that amplified somehow.
And because sound in
particular, at least for me,
is such a clue.
It's subtle emotional
undertoning too.
So there's another
purpose for having
a choice to put sound,
especially in something
like in space.
KEVIN GRAZIER: Well,
funny you should say that.
Because in the "Hollyweird
Science" books, we have boxes.
We separate some the
hardcore science, the math,
into science boxes.
So you don't have to read these.
They're not necessarily
part of the narrative.
You can skip right over them if
you don't want to do the math.
They'll add a
little extra insight
if you want to go there.
But they won't harm
the flow of the chapter
if you don't want to go there
and I want to do the math.
But we also have Meet
the Storyteller boxes,
where we take a storyteller,
like a director, a producer,
writer.
And we do a lot more of those
in the second and third book.
There's going to be
a third, by the way.
And one of those Meet
the Storyteller boxes we
have is with composer,
Bear McCreary.
And we talk about that, how a
film composer-- actually, this
is counter intuitive.
And as a storyteller, you
like counter intuitive.
Right?
The Meet the Storyteller
box with Bear
is in a chapter about
space navigation.
That initially might
be counter intuitive.
But in the end of
Battlestar-- spoiler alert--
the climactic instant of that
entire force for a season show
was a blend of
science and music.
And they tossed it to
Bear and myself and said,
you guys figure it out.
How does this work?
And we figured out
how those notes
got mapped to coordinates.
So that's hence, why
he's in navigation.
But Bear talks about
how important sound
is-- in his case, music--
as a storytelling mechanism,
and how important is it
in selling the story,
and how you would be watching.
And you'd be having a
different experience
if it wasn't for the music.
GIA MORA: Absolutely
KEVIN GRAZIER: And his belief
is if you notice his music,
even if you like it, he's
not done his job well.
You should like when you
buy the CD afterwards.
GIA MORA: So totally
disparate question.
KEVIN GRAZIER: OK.
GIA MORA: You worked on
"Pirates of the Caribbean"
KEVIN GRAZIER: I did.
Five.
The one that's
post-production right now.
GIA MORA: OK, great.
So tell us, since I
don't quite understand,
what is the science
behind a ghost ship?
And is there some
scientific evidence
to back up why Johnny Depp
is so hot in that movie?
That's what I'd like to know.
KEVIN GRAZIER: Scientific
evidence, I'm sure there is.
That's not my field.
But you just gave me
an idea for a science
box in the fifth book.
GIA MORA: Perfect.
You're welcome.
KEVIN GRAZIER: Thank you.
We have chapters
on neurosciences,
why we're all the
same, and psychology,
why we're all different.
We could probably fit
in somewhere in there.
GIA MORA: I like that.
KEVIN GRAZIER:
But anyway, as far
as "Pirates of Caribbean
5", what I can say--
and who knows how much of
what my input will survive--
but is that long before I
was even on the project,
you could Google-- ha,
product placement-- the film
and find a description
of the new female lead.
And you can see that originally
she's believed to be a witch.
And then it turns out,
she is a woman of science.
And they will sell how that
occurred in the mid 1700s.
But there is some
science that is
involved in their quest for some
artifact or goal, we'll say.
GIA MORA: Excellent.
KEVIN GRAZIER: And
that's all I can say,
is that there is
science involved.
And like a Science
Advisor should do,
is when you have some science--
your input's being solicited--
you give them options.
We can do this.
And this means this,
this, and this.
We can do this.
And this means this,
this, and this.
And you say, pick one
of these five options.
That's kind of what I did.
GIA MORA: Great.
It seems like an unlikely sort
of place for that to appear.
But obviously there's a
need for it in Hollywood.
So two-part question.
One, is how does one
become a Science Advisor?
And two, is can you tell us how
the science and entertainment
exchange has completely
revolutionized this call?
KEVIN GRAZIER: I can do both.
GIA MORA: Excellent.
KEVIN GRAZIER: And how I
got to be a Science Advisor
was somewhat more
difficult back then.
And it's more in the traditional
Hollywood mold of it's
not what you know.
It's who you know.
And back when Star Trek,
some of these series
were on, like "Next Generation"
and "Voyager" and DS Nine,
they would take
unsolicited manuscripts.
You could send in a script to
Paramount without an attorney,
without an agent.
And they would take it.
And they had a program
for looking at those
and potentially accepting those.
Now, Paramount,
they were honest.
They said, we get
about 3,000 a year.
And a good outcome
happens to single digits.
So we're talking about
roughly 1 in 1000 odds,
order of magnitude, right?
So my buddy, Jess,
Jess [? Sieger, ?]
who had been writing together
with me since we were 18--
because we did the college
radio thing together-- we
had an idea for a story.
And we wrote this
"Voyager" script.
I was in grad school.
And he was working full time
at Wright-Patterson Air Force
Base.
He has a family.
I was in grad school and
had a very, very demanding
dissertation advisor.
And that's a good thing.
And so we wrote this script in
what passed for our spare time,
and then sent it off to
Paramount and forgot it.
Paramount said, we'll
make you two promises.
It'll get read and
you'll get it back
between eight weeks
and eight months.
And that's all they
would promise you.
So we wrote this
"Voyager" script.
And we sent it in.
And then we forgot about it.
And seven months to the
day, I get a phone call
from the Executive Producer's
assistant saying that hey,
she loved your story.
Goes in a direction we
don't really want to go.
So we're not going
to use it verbatim.
Which, I should point
out, they eventually did
go in that direction.
Klingons in the Delta Quadrant.
Anyway, so they said,
we'd like to invite
you to come in and pitch.
So what you do is you develop
three to five short pitches.
And we'll schedule you
with a staff writer.
And you just go over
your story ideas.
It's, like, basically
just something succinct.
Like, here's an idea.
What if the Vidiians
want Neelix's other lung?
Or something like that.
That was really
obscure and nerdy.
You have to go back to the
early days of "Voyager".
So yeah, nerd cred, right?
You have to keep
establishing your nerd cred.
So you pitched those stories.
And overwhelmingly what you hear
is there's only so many ideas,
they say.
And we're all subject
to the same zeitgeist.
You almost always hear,
we just bought that.
We just said no to that.
We just shot that.
Most of my pitches already
had already been done.
Or in one case, the person
to whom I pitched kind of
chewed me out.
Well, that was
already established.
We obviated that
in this episode.
And he goes into
all these details.
That was on that
night's episode.
GIA MORA: Go figure, right?
KEVIN GRAZIER: Oh, well, hey
you want me to watch it now.
GIA MORA: Jeez, yeah.
KEVIN GRAZIER:
But to the people,
I got to pitch several times.
Because in the
first conversation
with the producer's
assistant, I asked,
is this something that
is a one-time thing?
Or can we come back?
And she goes, oh no,
you can come back
as long as you're not
arrogant, rude, or an idiot.
That's exactly what she's said.
I can still hear
her saying that.
And so I pitched several times.
And the two people to
whom I pitched most often
were Michael Taylor
and Bryan Fuller.
And they're both in their
first jobs in the industry.
Michael Taylor, I've gone
on work with on Battlestar,
on "Blood and Chrome", on
"Defiance", on "Virtuality".
And if you've not seen
that, it's worth a watch.
It was a pilot that
didn't get picked up.
Bryan Fuller, he's Bryan Fuller.
He's gone on to be huge.
I'm a big fan of
everything he's done.
From "Dead Like Me",
"Pushing Daisies",
and I was a huge "Hannibal" fan.
GIA MORA: Oh, yeah,
beautiful show.
KEVIN GRAZIER: Big Fannibal.
And when I saw some of Ron's
early Battlestar footage,
I'd stayed in contact with
both of these gentlemen.
I e-mailed Bryan.
I said, Bryan, please,
please, please please
get me an interview.
Maybe I didn't demean myself.
Who am I kidding?
Yes I did.
And Bryan hitched me to Ron
Moore, who interviewed me.
And I got the job.
And then "Eureka", it
turned out a season later,
"Eureka" and Battlestar
shared an office building
at Universal.
They shared the Rock
Hudson building.
And at a
getting-to-know-you lunch,
the two writers assistants
were sitting there.
Hey, how do you deal with
your technical problems?
We have this guy at JPL.
An hour later, I had a call.
I was on "Eureka".
GIA MORA: Wow!
KEVIN GRAZIER: So
GIA MORA: So it really is
once you're in the mill.
KEVIN GRAZIER: It is.
And at that point,
once I did Battlestar,
there's maybe two
or three people
in the industry who have
more experience at that.
So there's something
to be said for getting
valuable experience.
It's not only getting
your name out there.
It's, like, I've done this.
I've read a script.
I've red penned it.
I've given notes.
So that learning
curve is already
in the rear view mirror.
Now, today it's a lot easier
to become a Science Advisor
because there is the Science
and Entertainment Exchange.
The Exchange is actually a
part of the National Academy
of Sciences, people who are way
more accomplished than I ever
will be as a scientist.
But they have an office
here in Los Angeles.
It's actually physically
located on the campus of UCLA,
though there's no
formal affiliation.
And you call, I
think, 1-844-NEED-SCI.
I'm not sure about the
toll free part of that.
But you can look that
up on their website.
And you call the Exchange.
And you say, Hi, I'm a producer.
I'm doing a show about whatever.
Yeah, I'm actually
doing a series
based on the effects of gamma
rays in "Man in the Moon
Marigolds".
That's actually a film
from the late '60s.
And hey, I need somebody
who's a radiation expert.
And they will connect you.
They have a huge database.
So it's a lot easier for
people to get help these days.
And that feeds back
into what you said,
about people getting it right.
There is now a
much better avenue
for knowing what you're getting.
Because you're getting the
expertise of the people
at the Exchange, who know who's
in their database and know what
their expertise is.
And rather than just going
to the nearest college
and grabbing a scientist
and say, you'll do,
you have some knowledge built
into that huge database.
So it's a lot easier to
get accurate science.
And I think that plays into
why science is getting better,
simply because it's
easier to get it right.
GIA MORA: Well, it seems like
there's a nice reciprocity
between these two worlds, too.
That they want to
play fair together.
They want to play nice.
KEVIN GRAZIER: I
think so far, I think,
actually, Hollywood is
friendlier to science
than vice versa.
GIA MORA: Interesting.
KEVIN GRAZIER: I think
a lot of scientists
haven't fully embraced what
the entertainment history can
do for us in getting our
message out and getting
our science out, and
having people understand
what it is that we do.
I know a lot of scientists,
for example, don't particularly
care for "The Big Bang Theory".
Because they think it
shows them in a bad--
I think that's great for
the "Big Bang Theory".
Because one of the things that
isn't actively or often shown
is the culture of science.
And I will tell you, I have
never met any of those actors.
I've never been on the
set of "Big Bang Theory".
I've met their Science Adviser.
I've met David Saltzberg.
But I don't know him well.
But I'll tell you, I watch
"The Big Bang Theory",
and I know every one
of those characters.
GIA MORA: You know a scientist
who correlates to them?
KEVIN GRAZIER: Everyone.
Yes.
And the culture of
science is something
that since what you're seeing
is a snapshot of people's lives,
you don't really see, always,
the culture of science.
Because there's not really
opportunity to do that.
But you do on "The
Big Bang Theory".
You see more of the culture.
Let me back up a little
bit to a question
that you asked that
I skipped over.
Because I went off in this
direction, as I am want to do.
As far as the different shows,
I mentioned Science Faction,
like "Gravity"
and "The Martian".
Well, you mention Battlestar
and "Eureka" as well.
Those are two different shows.
And although the job Science
Advisor was a constant,
the job was
completely different.
And "Eureka" was about
the culture of science.
Here's an opportunity
where we got
to show people who
are really smart,
and how scientists interact.
And our Showrunner, Jaime
Paglia's dad, Donald Paglia,
was a research MD at UCLA.
He worked on "Biosphere 2".
And we consulted with
him on "Ascension",
when we did "Ascension".
So Jaime was motivated
to get science
and the culture of science
as right as possible,
along with the science, which
was a guest star every week.
A different type
of science came in
and guest starred every week.
Whereas on Battlestar,
the science
was a simple description
of people's day.
They just happened to be on the
run in space from the Cylons.
But if you were describing your
day here and now to someone
in say, 1966. when Star
Trek first started,
your day would be
science fiction.
I mean, it's well known now
that the flip phone was totally
taken after-- yeah, you can
tell I'm from the Valley.
Like, totally taken after.
GIA MORA: (VALLEY GIRL
ACCENT) Like, totally.
Ugh.
KEVIN GRAZIER: Whatever.
And taken after the
communicator from Star Trek.
Well, now the phones
that we have totally
leave that the dust
technologically wise.
GIA MORA: Sure.
KEVIN GRAZIER: The
smartphones-- do you ever
see Kirk get a text message?
Or do you see Spock, (IMITATING
SPOCK) Excuse me, Captain.
I am playing "Tetris".
No.
So that completely out paced it.
And for that matter,
Siri and Cortana
are smarter than the AI
was on the Enterprise.
I mean, they're pretty smart.
Have you ever asked Siri
to open the pod bay doors?
It's pretty amusing.
She has a whole repertoire.
GIA MORA: Oh, I love that.
KEVIN GRAZIER: Yeah.
So actually, those are pretty
smart, those assistants.
And I think they're,
in some ways,
smarter than some
of the AIs that
were shown in the mainframe
on the Enterprise,
whereas this is a handheld
device with a little bit
of network support.
GIA MORA: Right.
I don't know if
it's still active
or not, or if they've
closed it now.
But there was an XPRIZE to come
up with Bones's scanner too.
KEVIN GRAZIER:
Yeah, the Tricorder.
GIA MORA: The Tricorder.
KEVIN GRAZIER: And I just saw,
last week, there is a scanner.
And again, it links
to your phone.
And it does link
to the internet.
But you scan a food.
And it will come
up and say, bread.
This type of bread.
I think it will even
go to the manufacturer.
Basically, it's a
spectroscope, is what it is,
with a huge database.
And then it says,
this was calories.
This many carbs.
So you can scan your food.
And that's almost a
tricorder right there.
GIA MORA: Yeah, yeah.
I just need it to
do that and then
say, like, just a red flash,
like, do not eat this!
That's what I would need
for it to be useful.
KEVIN GRAZIER: And it's Friday
night, after a long week.
And you say, go-- yourself.
GIA MORA: I say, pizza.
Yeah, exactly.
I say, that's what
I'm happening.
It's Friday, kids.
It's pizza night.
KEVIN GRAZIER:
Yeah, that's right.
GIA MORA: Well, it's been such
a pleasure chatting with you.
KEVIN GRAZIER: It's been fun.
GIA MORA: I'm going to open
it up to the floor now.
We can have Livestream
questions as well.
You got the e-mail
address to send those to.
But for our live
studio audience,
please come up to
our microphone.
Tell us your name
and ask a question.
KEVIN GRAZIER: Don't
all rush up at once.
GIA MORA: Please, come on now.
We got one brave soul.
Hooray.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Josh.
KEVIN GRAZIER: Hey, Josh.
GIA MORA: Do you work
mostly in the pre-production
of a film or TV show?
Or is that also in post
or also during production?
Or what is your role
in different stages
of the development of a film?
KEVIN GRAZIER: That's actually
a really good question.
And that's entirely
show dependent.
On Galactica, for the most
part, I would get scripts
and I would send them notes.
I would say, do this or do that.
Or here's a suggestion.
Or you might want to try this.
Only one season did
I go in, in advance,
and talk about some science.
And that was before
season 3, when they said,
we're going to
really start to get
serious about finding Earth.
So we've been looking at
the Prophecies of Pythia,
if you remember.
So what are things we can have
from the Prophecies of Pythia,
that can be omens or portents,
and help us lead to Earth?
So we want astronomical
events that that
could have been talked about.
And here's an
interesting aside, which
has kind of under the radar, one
thing I like about Galactica,
is that-- this is
completely afield.
And so I'll try to
come dragging back
to answer the rest
of your question.
But what's cool about
Galactica is all the things,
all the questions, or
all the little things
that we slipped in there
that hardly anyone noticed.
And the cool example is Pythia.
If you remember the
show, President Roslin
was keen on the
Prophecies of Pythia.
Because she thought that
was going to lead us
to Earth and a new home.
Right?
And those were in
their sacred scrolls.
Well, we learn in season three,
that these aren't prophecies.
She was actually
on a trip to Earth.
So this is more a travelogue
than it was prophetic.
Since she was on a trip to
Earth, Pythia was a Cylon.
And you remember in season
1, when in an early episode,
Six tells Baltar, we
know your religious text
better than you do.
Because one of us wrote them.
And if you get it, you get it.
And if you don't, it
flows under the radar.
And it may enhance your
appreciation if you do get it.
But it doesn't harm
it if you don't.
OK?
But it's that level.
It's just describing
stuff or making sure
that it's consistent
and selling the world.
In "Eureka"-- and that's
the end member example--
until the last
episode of "Defiance",
I did everything on "Eureka"
that I ever did for any show
in "Eureka".
So I would come in
before the season start
and talk about here's
some cool new science
we might be able to use.
Of course, there's
always a thematic link.
This science should link somehow
to what this character is going
through, what their journey is.
So there's always
a thematic link
between the science
and the story.
And it's all about the story.
But then I would go in
at maybe outlying stage,
and say, we can do
this or we can do that.
And then I would get the
scripts to give notes on.
But later, I would actually
look at special effects and say,
this looks good.
Or maybe we can do this.
I would get calls
from Vancouver.
Is it "Had-ron" or "Hey-dron?"
It's either, actually.
It's one of those things.
I can go either way.
GIA MORA: Yes, I've
heard it both ways.
Wait, so Vancouver,
because that's
where they were shooting?
KEVIN GRAZIER: That's where
they're shooting, in Vancouver.
GIA MORA: OK, just to clarify.
KEVIN GRAZIER:
Yeah, they literally
shot next door to Battlestar 2.
GIA MORA: Because
I was, like, wait.
The Hadron Collider is
over in [INAUDIBLE].
KEVIN GRAZIER: No, no, no.
Yeah, but they shot
right next to Battlestar,
in the same studios.
GIA MORA: Ah.
KEVIN GRAZIER: And one time, in
the third episode, episode 103,
I got a call.
We had, like, five
whiteboards full of equations.
And it has to sell this
thing they're working on.
So I literally wrote five
whiteboards of equations.
I think I faxed them
up to Vancouver.
And I was floored when
it came on screen.
And it was in my handwriting.
No idea how that happened.
OK, so there's all these
things I did, ranging
from pre-production to post.
And like I said, until the
last episode of "Defiance",
I did everything
on "Eureka" that I
did for any other series.
But on "Defiance", I
actually got a little bit
of input into some of the set
design aboard [? Soros, ?]
which was the Omec
ship at the very end,
if you saw "Defiance".
Anybody see "Defiance"?
No?
GIA MORA: No.
KEVIN GRAZIER: No
one saw "Defiance"?
GIA MORA: OK, well, now
you know what you're
going to binge this weekend.
Right?
KEVIN GRAZIER: Yeah,
highly recommend it.
GIA MORA: Awesome.
KEVIN GRAZIER:
Season one was good.
Season two and three
were off the hook.
I love that show.
I miss all three of those shows.
I miss "Eureka".
I miss Battlestar.
Would love to do something
Battlestar related again.
But anyway, does that
answer the question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
KEVIN GRAZIER: OK.
GIA MORA: Awesome.
Next?
AUDIENCE: Hi, my name's Kevin.
You talked about the
Oh Please moments.
KEVIN GRAZIER: Yeah.
GIA MORA: Do you have
some that you regret?
Or are there things
that you wish
you had fought more for in some
of the movies that you've done?
KEVIN GRAZIER:
You'd be surprised
how often I get that question.
The question is--
I'll paraphrase it--
what's your biggest screw
up as a Science Advisor?
How's that?
You were obviously much
more polite about it.
But yeah, I've got a big one.
I got a big shiny one.
And the reason I can
talk about it openly--
well, I would anyway.
Because you know, we can
write a book about it.
Because it's always a
teachable moment-- but this
is one that I saw coming, and
I figured it out way too late.
But in the second
episode of Battlestar,
the Galactica is doing underway
replenishment of a ship called
the Virgon Express.
Which means they got lines
between the two ships.
They're pumping
water and/or fuel
or whatever, from Galactica
to the Virgon Express.
So they're physically
mated together.
And then there is
an act of sabotage
in which there were several
explosive charges in the water
holes on Galactica,
that explode and blow
outside of the Galactica.
And all this water is venting.
And Galactica goes nowhere.
That would have imparted
what we call a Delta-v,
or a change of velocity.
And it would have
either pulled it apart
from the Virgon Express, or at
least pulled them a little bit.
They would have had to
course correct for that.
And that is
something we probably
could have oversold
for dramatic effect.
Because we know that would
have imparted a momentum.
And we probably could
have said it imparted more
than it really might have.
And by the time I go,
oh no, I missed this,
and quick e-mail, I said, oh no.
There's this.
And they said, sorry,
that ship's sailed.
Ha ha ha ha.
Ship's sailed.
So that was my biggest one.
But let me go the
other direction,
where we knew the science.
But it was a filmmaker's choice.
When I first met with
the Cuarons-- plural.
That's Alfonso and Jonas,
who co-wrote in screenplay,
in "Gravity" [INAUDIBLE].
We were in Chateau
Marmont, on Sunset,
in the lobby talking
about the film
and what they were trying to
achieve and their motivation.
The IMAX film for the
Hubble Servicing Mission
was a big motivation
for that film.
Which you watched
that IMAX film,
and you can see that totally.
There's that word again.
GIA MORA: Totally.
KEVIN GRAZIER: And
I said, well, here's
the one thing you're going
to have an issue with,
is that the closest the orbit
of Hubble and ISS ever get
is-- now, this is an
absolute best case.
This will never happen
in the real world--
I said, is roughly between
here and the Mexican border.
You can't get from one
orbit-- and they're
different inclinations too.
And it's hard to
change your tilt.
You're not going to get
from one orbit to another
in the shuttle, let alone with
one backpack of gas and oxygen.
So that's your gimme.
That's your suspend disbelief.
Go with us on this one
really fantastic thing.
And we'll be more faithful to
the science the rest of the way
out.
So that was a choice.
But it was a choice.
There was options on the table.
I said, here's an idea.
We know that the
shuttle will not
be flying by the time
this film comes out.
It's scheduled for retirement.
And this is going to
take a while to make.
Because this is
an ambitious film.
So it's a reasonable
design constraint
that the next
generation telescope
be serviceable from ISS easily.
So I said, here's an idea.
We've got a strong female lead.
It's very female
centric, the story.
So why don't we thematically
link a new space telescope
that's closer to ISS?
And we'll call it
the Cannon Space
Telescope, for
Annie Jump Cannon,
an early female astronomer?
And then we hit up Canon camera
for product placement dollars.
And there's this long pause.
You missed your calling in life.
You should've been a producer.
But one thing also, another
aside is that a lot of people
don't realize this--
and it's on the extras.
But some people don't
watch the extras.
There is actually a
companion film to "Gravity".
If you haven't seen it,
I highly recommend it.
It's only short.
It's between 6 and
10 minutes long.
It's a short film.
It's called "Aningaaq"--
A-N-I-N-G-A-A-Q.
And if you remember when-- and
my voice cracked. (SINGING)
Happy puberty to you.
Anyway, so-- Dr.
Stone is aboard-- God.
I don't remember.
She's in the Soyuz module.
She gets a brief
contact with someone
who's not speaking English.
And she makes out
his name is Aningaaq.
Remember, she's
howling with the dogs?
AUDIENCE: Mhm.
KEVIN GRAZIER: This
is that conversation
from the other side.
AUDIENCE: Oh!
KEVIN GRAZIER: It's
actually on an ice floe,
in a frozen patch of
ice north of Norway.
And he's speaking Inuit.
So it's Aningaaq's
story of that.
It's great.
It's only short.
GIA MORA: It's the Rosenkranz
and Guildenstern to "Hamlet".
Right?
KEVIN GRAZIER: Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
It is.
And have you ever seen it?
GIA MORA: No.
I saw it in the theater.
So I didn't have the DVD.
KEVIN GRAZIER: It's on YouTube.
It's worth seeing.
And it's official Warner
Brothers production,
written by Jonas Cuaron,
directed by Jonas.
So I recommend that.
It's worth your time.
GIA MORA: Very cool.
KEVIN GRAZIER: You'll watch
it more than once, promise.
GIA MORA: You have
so many things
to now watch over your weekend.
This is going to be great.
Please, come on up.
KEVIN GRAZIER: Did I
answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
KEVIN GRAZIER: OK.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my name's Tom.
I was wondering, is there
any particular sorts
of things that happened that
you wish people did better
in the movies?
Where is the place
to improve on?
KEVIN GRAZIER: The
question is, is there
things places people did
better and places to improve?
You know, I can't say-- yes.
Yes, there is.
I was going to say, I can't
point to any one theme.
But I think there
is one that bugs me.
It's not even my field.
Usually you'll find
that scientists
will overlook bad science
if it's not in their field.
And then if it is in their
field, we're fighting.
I have a problem with you.
And since I'm an
orbit dynamics person,
so I at least am glad I
had some say in "Gravity".
Science isn't perfect in that.
But it's as best as we
could make it and still tell
that story.
But the one thing that irks
me to death is the 10% myth.
The we only use
10% of our brains.
Imagine if we could use it all.
Now, what's funny
is in "Eureka",
we have a character who says,
we only use 10% of our brains
at any given time.
Imagine if we could use
it-- and that qualifier
didn't make it right.
But it made it more
closer to being right.
And then people jumped
all over me and said,
did you listen to what he said?
So I at least got that
done better in "Eureka"
than has been done.
But yeah, the 10% myth irks me.
And you know, "Lucy" was
based on that premise.
And "Limitless" is too.
But I think "Limitless"
sells a little better.
But I was reading
recently about quicksand.
How does quicksand
relate to this?
Quicksand is a trope that was
done to death in the '60s.
And it was always a source
of jeopardy in westerns.
And now it's been years
since you've seen quicksand.
Because we all
know that survival.
You float.
You just lay back and float.
And you just wait for
somebody to pull you out.
So quicksand has just gone away.
And it was overused.
I'm hoping that
the 10% myth goes
the direction of quicksand.
It's been overused.
We've milked that
for all it's worth.
And we all know
it's just not true.
So can we just move on?
And that's one thing.
We kind of harped on that in
the "Hollyweird Science" books,
and haven't even got to
the neuroscience chapter.
And that's in book three.
Oh, by the way, we added a
neuroscientist, Dr. Jessica
Cail, who's a psycho
pharmacologist at Pepperdine.
She's on as an author in
the third book as well.
So that stuff, I'm sure
she'll have something
to say about the 10% myth.
I have no doubt she'll be
opinionated on that topic.
GIA MORA: Come on ahead.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Nick.
Unfortunately, or well, I
guess, fortunately, you actually
just answered my question
answering his question.
I was going to ask about
some of your biggest gripes
about popular misconceptions
that you get, maybe,
nitpicked on.
Like you were mentioning
earlier about people nitpicking,
but they were actually wrong.
KEVIN GRAZIER: I've got
another one that I can tell,
and this is from Battlestar.
In an episode in
season 3-- gosh,
they're kind of
blending together-- we
had a situation where Chief
Tyrol and his wife, Cally,
were both maintenance workers.
The fleet is low on
maintenance workers.
So they're overworked.
They're stressed.
And the Chief has
a simple repair.
He's going to repair a slow
leak in a freight air lock.
And this is an easy repair.
So he assigns his
wife to join him,
simply so they can spend
some time together.
[THUD]
That was my phone falling out
my pocket, hitting the stage
floor, by the way.
Thank goodness for
[INAUDIBLE] cases.
Anyway, so he assigns his
wife to work with him, Cally.
And then they're in working
in this freight air lock.
And the inner door triggers.
And now we are stuck.
And they can't get it open.
We're stuck in an air lock
that's slowly evacuating.
And rather than having something
that resembles some quality
time together, we're going to
die and leave behind an orphan.
And orphans don't do
well in the fleet.
So now this nice pleasant
sort of leisurely day
has turned into a danger
that's threatening our lives
and our bloodline, so to speak.
Anyway, so they're
in this air lock.
It's evacuating.
And since it's evacuating,
it's getting cold as well.
So it's cold.
It's damp.
And the solution
to this problem is
to place a Raptor
outside a spacecraft,
evacuate it, put
people in space suits.
Open it up.
Blow the explosive bolts on
the door, and blow it out.
And the remaining air
pushes our characters out.
They're caught by the Raptor,
close it, repressurize.
Treat for the symptoms.
OK?
Now, two complaints-- none
of which were justified--
happened overwhelmingly
with that.
And that has been done before.
Part of it, without the exposure
to space was done in 2001.
And a very similar
thing was done--
and I didn't realize at
the time-- in "Titan A.E."
An animated film that Joss
Whedon wrote, by the way--
is people said,
well, they freeze.
Everyone knows space is cold.
It's very cold in space.
I do a crappy Khan.
Anyway, yes, it's 2.7 kelvins.
But you need a medium
to carry away the heat.
You'll notice that
room-temperature bathwater
is colder than
room-temperature air
because there's a denser medium.
There's no medium.
So to rid yourself of heat,
you need to radiate that away.
And that is a slow process.
So they're
functionally insulated.
They're not going
to lose any heat
in that short trip between
the air lock and the Raptor.
Then people who saw "Outland",
which was a movie, an '81 film,
supposedly about mining.
And it was "High Noon" on Io, is
what it was, with Sean Connery.
They had an effect that
they were partial to,
where people exposed to
the vacuum of space popped.
And then there was the
end of "Total Recall",
where Arnold and
Melina-- I'm trying
to remember Arnold's name.
I'm blanking on it.
I keep coming up with
Cohaagen. But Cohaagen was also
on the surface with them.
Quaid.
Melina and Quaid were
on the surface of Mars,
and their eyes were
bugging out and stuff.
And people said, oh,
they would have popped.
And no, they wouldn't have.
If they didn't
hold their breath,
the air is going to take the
path of least resistance.
And it's going to come out their
mouth and nose for the most
part.
Now, some air is going to be
trapped in small blood vessels.
You might get blood
vessels burst in the eye.
Maybe the eardrum will puncture,
nosebleed and things like that.
But that's survivable.
In fact, astronauts
early in the program
were exposed to the
vacuum and survived it.
And in fact, what happens
is when they bring them
back aboard, you see
Chief getting out
of bed in the sick bay slowly.
Because the Bends
attacks the joints.
And he's in a lot of pain.
And then he goes
next to the room.
And Cally is in a
hyperbaric chamber.
Because it was harder
on her, because she's
(WHISPERING) not a Cylon.
And he looks down at her
in the hyperbaric chamber.
And when she looks over at
him, if you look closely,
the blood vessels in
her eye had popped.
And what's really fun
is that because we
caught so much
crap with that, we
did a film called "The Plan".
Has anyone seen "The Plan"?
Or has anyone not
seen "The Plan"?
If you didn't know it, you got
two more hours of Battlestar
to watch.
It's basically "The
Plan" is the first two
years of the Galactica, told
more or less, from the Cylon's
view point.
And it was written
by Jane Espenson,
who is, in part, responsible
for us being here today.
Jane, after we got so many
people who griped about that,
we actually had
somebody-- a Cylon,
rather than face his wife-- with
whom he was very much in love--
rather than face her when she
is armed with the knowledge
that he is actually a Cylon,
he decided to commit suicide.
And he blows himself
out an air lock.
And again, it rushes out.
And as the air expands,
the humidity in your breath
would freeze.
And then you see him after
this event has occurred.
And he's got crystals of ice
around his mouth and nose,
which is basically
saying, hmm! to the people
who complained the first time.
AUDIENCE: You are very good
at answering my questions
before I ask them.
Because I was going
to ask, again,
what's your way of setting
the record straight?
KEVIN GRAZIER: The
way of setting record
straight is just by writing
"Hollyweird Science".
And you know,
"Hollyweird Science"
is about talking about
accurate science,
setting the record
straight sounds
like get-evenism a little bit.
And I'm not beneath that.
There is some that in book two.
Some of the complaints
about "Gravity" that
were non complaints-- we
actually cover the Chief
and Cally issue in that book.
And in "Sunshine"-- the
2007 film, "Sunshine"--
you see somebody
exposed to space.
His arm gets hit
and it shatters.
And we said, well, no.
But also, some of the
complaints about "Gravity", we
say, well, about getting
from one orbit to another?
Completely valid.
That was a choice.
But some of the
other complaints,
like the scene where
she has to let them go,
there are a lot of
complaints about that.
There's nothing wrong with
the physics of that scene.
But a lot of people complained.
And we actually go step
by step what happened,
and why there's nothing
wrong with that.
So there is some setting
the record straight,
simply because this was
a high profile film.
And a lot of people had issues
with some of the elements
that weren't really issues.
So I'm perfectly fine
with saying what was wrong
if it's something I worked on.
But a lot of things, a lot
of complaints weren't wrong.
AUDIENCE: Well, on that
note, I'd like to thank you.
And I think we'd all
like to thank you
for coming to Google today.
GIA MORA: Thank you so
much for joining us.
Dr. Kevin Grazier.
Thank you guys for coming out.
Thanks, Livestreamers.
KEVIN GRAZIER:
Thanks for coming.